equal one node on our graph. Using nodes on a graph is very intuitive and that is
fortunate because it corresponds to many applications. Many times when you want to model something that corresponds to a
series of nodes connected together, if the groupings are binary like zero or one or included and not included in a
set, you can simply and naturally map these nodes into bits or cubits.
In this example, and even in the one that we scaled up to 100 cubits in episode 3, the graph connectivity
already matched the topology of our superconducting hardware. So we didn't need to concern ourselves with that either. Now that's not always the case.
And if you have a more complicated or connected graph than the examples that we highlighted so far, you are going to
need to implement swap gates. But this is handled actually at the second step of kisskit patterns which is concerned
with transpolation. The other part of the max cut problem that makes it so handy is that we
already know how to express the cost function as a Hamiltonian using the cubo formulation.
Recall that in quantum computing and variational quantum algorithms, a Hamiltonian cost function is a function
that encodes the optimal solution of the problem in the ground state of the Hamiltonian.
To construct the cost Hamiltonian, we were able to use the sparse poly op class in kiskuit to specify the
connectivity of our graph and the mapping stage to the quantum operators is done. And the quantum circuit was
simply the QAOA on Zots. Now, if this isn't ringing a bell, please go back and check out episode 3 where we walk
through this in much more detail. Now, let's up the difficulty ever so slightly. Next, we are going to look
into an example modeled in the paper called resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding written by
IBM in collaboration with the University of New South Wales. A little biochemistry background. Proteins are
macroolelecules composed of long chains of amino acids. These long chains fold
in complex structures that perform a wide variety of biological functions.
Determining a protein structure in a three-dimensional space and understanding the relationships between
structure and function are among the most challenging problems in biochemistry today.
Proteins fold into useful structures due to interactions between the amino acids themselves.
As the structure twists and folds, amino acids that are far from each other on the chain might end up right next to
each other and may interact strongly. We need to get a Hamiltonian describing all of these interactions between amino
acids if we want to predict what final structure will minimize the energy. Here we will focus on amino acid chains and
how they can be modeled on a quantum computer and then how we can obtain interam amino acid distances for
calculation of the interaction energies.
With this, we actually will have gathered all the necessary contributions to the Hamiltonian in order to simulate
it on a quantum computer. In real proteins, amino acids can occupy a continuum of possible locations.
However, we are going to use a simplification here and restrict them to a lattice model where each amino acid
occupies a point on a grid. Here, the authors used a tetrahedral lattice.
Quick note here we are encoding the direction of the edges and not the nodes themselves like in the max cut problem.
Each cubit represents a possible singlestep path along the tetrahedral grid. Note that the adjacent sites have
been labeled in this diagram as A or B because of their different orientations in the lattice.
The protein chain is represented as a series of turns or directions on this
lattice. Each turn between the amino acids can be in one of four directions
corresponding to the edges of the tetrahedrin.
These four possible turns are encoded using four cubits.
This sounds a bit tricky. So let's look at this example in a little more depth.
Let's place our first amino acid chain on this point in the tetrahedral lattice. The direction to the first
amino acid chain to the second is arbitrary because the system can always just be rotated to make that edge point
in any direction we like. So let's place our second amino acid here. It's not as
easy to see, but the path from the second to the third is actually also arbitrary. All three choices would
result in having two of the edges with an angle of approximately 109.5°
between them. Picking this second edge simply determines the orientation of our protein in space. So without loss of
generality at all, we can choose the first turns to just be 0 0 1 and 0 0 1
0. With these simplifications, the configuration of the amino acid chain is simply given by this expression.
So far we have mapped the tetrahedrin edges to cubits and our quantum circuit will be an onzoth. Now we need to
consider how to encode the energy of the problem into a Hamiltonian so that its ground state gives us the optimal
folding pattern. Now for any given configuration there will be an associated energy due to the
interactions between the amino acids themselves. These interactions are strongest when the two amino acids are
close to each other. Obviously amino acids that are adjacent in the backbone of the chain will always interact with
each other. But because the protein can twist and fold, other amino acid pairs
can also interact. Amino acids 10 and 20, for example, might end up being on
adjacent sites after the protein has folded. Amino acids that end up being near each other have stronger
interactions and drive the folding process, but they do not necessarily have indices that are close to each
other. So we need a formula to describe the distance D between amino acids I and
J using the information encoded on the configuration cubits. That way we can
use their separation distance to determine how strongly they are interacting. This is a bit complicated
but bear with me because it's a neat trick. First, let's introduce a function f sub a of i that indicates whether or